one of the most successful tv franchises
of the 21st century will roar back to
cbs after a five-year hiatus when csi
vegas premieres on october 2021 with
some of the franchise's biggest stars
back in action the new series the fifth
in the franchise will be the first csi
since a short-lived csi cyber was
cancelled in 2016 and fans are excited
for the return of a trio of actors
remembered fondly by fans of the
original csi which ran from 2000 to 2015
and chronicled the forensic
investigators of the las vegas police
crime lab yes william peterson is back
as team leader gil grissom as is wallace
langham a csi technician david hodges
along with fan favorite georgia fox
scientist sarah seidel but as fans
anticipate the impending csi comeback
many are also wondering about another
original cast member george eats who
played forensic scientist nick stokes
and recalling the time that both eids
and fox were unceremoniously fired from
the series
if you missed the behind the scenes
drama from 2004 you'd never know the duo
was let go because they were rehired
very soon after but at the time when csi
was riding high in the ratings it was
shocking that two popular performers
whose characters were beloved by fans
would be let go so abruptly so why did
cbs end up firing george eads and
georgia fox from csi when the program
was in its prime back in 2004 csi was
the most viewed drama on television and
edes and fox were looking to cash in on
such success although their contracts
paid them a hefty 100 000 per episode
which amounted to 2.2 million dollars
per season the actors felt the show's
increasingly impressive viewership
numbers should have been better
reflected in their paychecks in pursuit
of significant raises that they felt
they deserved both of them quickly
showed that they were more than willing
to play hardball with cbs to make it
happen as reported by entertainment
weekly in july of 2004 eids and fox were
threatening to skip work on csi
altogether unless the network increased
their pay sure enough they carried out
their plan leaving behind roughly 6.6
million dollars apiece that they would
have earned over the next three years
and cbs promptly made examples out of
them by firing them
looks like someone stepped in horse crap
is failure to show up for work one
morning and fox's inability to fax back
a signed pledge stating she would not do
the same reportedly served as the
catalyst for the network's bold move
suffice to say it didn't take long for
either actor to change their tune in the
days to come cbs's punishment worked
seeing as within relatively no time at
all the stars were issuing public
apologies and offering explanations for
why the situation fell into such
disarray fox attested that she had
signed the pledge but put it in the mail
that needs insisted he had only
accidentally overslept with the latter
referring to the drama is a big
misunderstanding in response cbs
relented and rehired both actors but at
a cost no new raises even though some
other cast members saw their salaries
increased had they played ball in the
first place and agreed to extend their
contracts by one more year they'd have
each earned an extra 20 thousand dollars
per episode though this may seem like
the happy ending everyone was waiting
for this tale isn't over just yet heeds
was again given an involuntary leave of
absence from csi in 2013 according to
the hollywood reporter after he
initiated an altercation with a staff
writer voicing frustrations over the
direction of his character he also once
again left the series just before the
show's finale two years later he then
went on to co-star on cbs's macgyver
only to exit that series prematurely as
well
what's encyclopedia brown up to
i never really know it's part of his
charm i guess
fox briefly left csi a second time in
2007 but her departure this time was
amicable and short-lived she'd returned
to the program by the time the next
season rolled around and stayed until
the end all these years later fox is
coming back for the newest version of
csi and fans can only hope she'll hold
on to the job this time around
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]